[Music]
stoke-on-trent one time the heart of
industrial England a powerhouse of coal
iron and steel but above all pottery
making in the 50s seventy thousand
people were employed and steaks
potteries now there are less than ten
thousand companies like Emma Bridgewater
are still keeping the craft alive but
it's one of the very last examples of a
traditional skill once famous throughout
the world this is a city that still
takes such pride in its heritage of
craftsmanship and manufacturing but
somewhere along the way the people
stoke-on-trent central have lost their
faith in politicians at the last
election turnout here was lower than in
any other constituency why I think
people have given up they have they've
given up they don't know they're not
really believing anything that people
are saying anymore they don't they're
promising all sorts and it's not coming
coming through emotion most of the time
I'm not voting anymore
I think all this brexit thing that's
going on I've just not they don't listen
and they've done it then they're trying
to change your mind so I I'm not voting
anymore
in spite of the apathy the constituency
is now the focus of a crucial
by-election largely seen as a two-way
battle between UK and labour for the
English working class state obviously
the other main parties aren't ready to
concede just yet
I caught up with the locally born
Conservative candidate when he was out
canvassing I've lived in the city my
entire life and also obviously regs it
is a real issue on the doorstep and only
the Prime Minister has got that clear
plan to deliver exit so it is important
that we respect that result that was
voted on overwhelmingly by local people
and the Lib Dems aren't giving up either
people have no say at the moment at this
time Liam Fox they were theorists and
Boris Johnson tries to stitch up a deal
which people do not necessarily like
they were not given at a time when a
referendum happened so what Liberal
Democrats than me are standing is to
have another say for the people and
people to decide rather than a few
member of Parliament's are cabinet
ministers deciding it
their optimism stems from the
controversy surrounding the two
candidates widely regarded as having the
best chance of winning both labour and
Jacob have some very embarrassing
skeletons in their closet on Twitter
you've referred to brexit as a massive
pile of something that I can't possibly
send television how's that gone down on
stake the things I said on Twitter I've
apologized for I'm not proud of the
language that I've used but when I made
that particular tweet it was in
frustration at the fact that four months
after the referendum vote the Prime
Minister hasn't come forward with any
plans or we were getting were vague sort
of comments about hard brexit soft
brexit red white and blue brexit and as
my way of saying how frustrated I was in
hindsight probably better ways to have
done it now we also had an interview set
up with the UK candidates Paul Nuttall
but he pulled out so we're going to try
and find him the reason for his
disappearing act
false comments that appeared on his
website about losing close friends at
Hillsborough he now says he deeply
regrets this but still others to do a
performance what do you make of the
situation regarding the Hillsborough
comments that mr. Russell is made and
since retracted I've just been out all
morning knocking on doors and stoke it's
going incredibly well I think Paul's
gonna do it I think we stand a real
chance of having a second MP this town
has been a Labour fiefdom since 1950
Paul Nuttall is the chance to give state
real change thank you and what about the
hills were comments
we're just trying to find Paul Nuttall I
bet especially know where he is I
haven't seen him
yeah we're trying to track him down oh
so it looks like it's Paul Nuttall's
office here just get in time find if
he's inside
hello how you doing I hope so I'm safer
with Sky News uh-huh I just wish you
knew where Paul nacelles I think if you
come in and ask our coordinator you
might get a and I'm sure you apply it
because I don't know thank you
hi we just we just want to find out
where Paul nicely especially Mary well
sure thank you one of mr. Nuttall team
was summoned for an explanation was
somewhat camera-shy hello right how's it
going we're on the were on the hunt for
mr. Nuttall I know you even speak to
storm I don't suppose you've got any
update for us yes the yuca candidate was
now busy writing a speech for his
party's spring conference we were told
but our request for an interview was
still being considered usually in a
by-election the candidates try their
very best to try and win the thing but
this time after a string of
controversies it's almost as if the
front one is a trying their best to
throw it away the people stoke-on-trent
would be forgiven for thinking that they
deserve a bit better than that given the
potential significance of this
by-election it seems a shame that so
little is being offered by so much of
the political establishment to the very
few who will even bother to vote
[Music]
you